Speaker 1: OK, getting back a little bit
to the issue of twenty twenty two, David,
should Republicans run on returning to normal
in twenty twenty two? So I mentioned earlier in
terms of what twenty, twenty two is looking like,
one way Republicans could run is on stuff like
Biden's a communist, Biden's a socialist,
you know, mandatory inoculations and
Biden failed on Afghanistan and all these
different things. That's that's one way to do it.
The other way Republicans could run it is
because it's time to return to normal. Right now,
you and I know these Republicans have been saying
return to normal from day one of the pandemic.
They never wanted any break from the normal.
They were always the ones saying just don't just
leave everything open, don't close anything,
go on and on and on. The things that were
required to return to normal masking guidelines,
vaccination, they don't want to do any of them,
and yet they still want to return to normal. So
the reality is, if Republicans had had their way,
things would have remained normal all along
and we would have endless more coronavirus
death right now. But that doesn't matter because
what matters is what can you sell to your voters?
Twenty, twenty two comes and Republicans run
on. Let's return to normal. The truth is,
what they'd really be doing is they'd be running
on returning to pretending that things are normal.
I think they might package it as getting America
back to work, reopening America, whatever.
They would figure out some way to do it that
would evade or escape responsibility for the
fact that they want to ease every restriction and
forget about vaccines and forget about all of it.
But the truth is, it is a more positive message.
It's a more positive message in many ways. And so
when it was Trump running against Biden
and things were out of control and Trump
mismanaged everything, the sober message from
Joe Biden and from Democrats generally of
we've got to be careful. We should
be careful here. We should be careful
there. Here's a plan to reopen schools, but
we don't just reopen everything willy nilly.
That sounded more mature. It sounded more adult.
It sounded more sensible. The difference now is
because this is continuing to drag on, in part
thanks to the vaccinated, to the unvaccinated,
rather, who are not going to go and get themselves
vaccinated. The idea of a more positive approach,
a more positive message probably is going to sound
good to a lot of people. So now if Republicans
come in and they keep it positive, they don't
go Joe Biden, the authoritarian, whatever,
but they go it's time to reopen America. The Sun
is coming up on a post pandemic world. Let's get
back to work. Let's get back to normal. I think
there's a really good chance that it works.
Now, ultimately, what it will really depend on
is how does the pandemic turn out over the next
nine months, 10 months in states like Florida,
where it's a complete health escape right now
in states like Texas, where things are not
going well, but the governor just tested
positive for covid. If it continues to be a
total catastrophe and the election gets close,
Democrats should be able to just point out, look
at where the irresponsible Republican policies
have gotten us at the state level. You want this
nationally now? No, no, no. That can't be that may
be something that becomes a reality depending
on how bad things go. On the other hand, if no
thanks to these Republican governors cases turn
around, we get we prevent whatever is the next
variant from becoming completely out of control,
vaccination rate goes up, et cetera. Doesn't
really matter that it was not the Republican
policies that got us there. Republicans will be
able to run on. It's now time. Let's do it.
We'll do it. We'll get things reopened. So
a lot of question marks remain, but Republicans
running in twenty two on Let's Get Back to normal
has the potential because of the ignorance of so
many of their voters to actually work. We've got
a great bonus show for you today. Make sure you're
signed up at join Pakman dot com. We will speak to
you then. I'm here next week. No more vacation.
No more vacation. I am here all week weekend.